TONIGHT CORRESPONDENT TALKS
ABOUT THE BAD TIMING FOR THOSE
OF YOU DRIVING DURING SUMMER
VACATION.
>> IT IS HARD NOT TO NOTICE,
EVEN WHEN YOU CANNOT BEAR TO
LOOK.
>> I'M SCARED TO DEATH, BECAUSE
I GET PENNED ON THAT EXTRA MONEY
FOR MY CAR AND GROCERIES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
>> GIESE PRESSES ON THE RISE,
THE CRUNCH FOR COMMUTERS THAT
STRETCHES THE FAMILY BUDGET.
>> WHEN I STARTED GAS WAS $2.20
PER GALLON, NOW IT IS UP TO $3
PER GALLON DEPENDING ON WHERE
YOU SHOP, THAT MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE.
>> THE USUAL TALK OF THE SUMMER
DRIVING SEASON BEING THE REASON
FOR THE RISE IS OUT THERE, BUT
EXPERTS SAY THERE IS MORE AT
WORK HERE THAN JUST THE
CALENDAR.
CONCERNS ABOUT THE IRAN NUCLEAR
DEAL FALLOUT FOR ONE.
WHICH SOME SPECULATE COULD TREND
GLOBAL SUPPLIES.
CONSIDER OILS PLUNGED FROM $100
A BARREL TO JUST BELOW $30 A
BARREL IN 2016.
AND ACCORDINGLY PRICES FELL, BUT
SINCE THEN THEY HAVE BEEN ON THE
RISE WITH WEST TEXAS CRUDE, THE
U.S. BENCHMARK TOPPING $71 A
BARREL.
AS IT IS UP 14% FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
AND MORE PAYING AT THE PUMP WITH
THEIR NATIONAL PRICE PER GALLON
AVERAGING $2.84, UP $0.19 OVER
LAST MONTH AND $0.51 HIGHER THAN
THIS TIME LAST YEAR.
EXPERTS SAY THAT IS IN PART
BECAUSE WALL STREET TRADERS
ANTICIPATED THE PRESIDENT'S
DECISION TO PULL OUT OF THE IRAN
DEAL.
>> THE MARKET WAS PREPARED FOR
THE U.S. TO PULL OUT, A CAMPAIGN
PROMISE THAT HE HAS BEEN KNOWN
TO DO WHATEVER HE CAN IN HIS
POWER WHETHER GOOD OR BAD FOR
THE PRESENT SITUATION TO KEEP
THE CAMPAIGN PROMISES.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS ALSO
PROMISED TO RETALIATE AGAINST
THOSE WHO MANIPULATE THE PRICE
OF OIL.
TWEETING THAT IT LOOKS LIKE OPEC
IS ADDED AGAIN.
OIL PRICES ARE ARTIFICIALLY VERY
HIGH.
NO GOOD.
AND WILL NOT BE ACCEPTED.
>> EXPERTS ARGUE THAT FRANKLY
NOT MUCH OF THAT THE PRESIDENT
CAN DO ABOUT THE PROBLEM SHORT
OF TAPPING THE NATION'S
STRATEGIC RESERVES.
THAT IS A MOVE THAT THEY SAY